[Music]
uh what's up mkbhd here
all right iphone 12 pro max the big boy
so if you've seen the reviews of iphone
12 and iphone 12 pro you probably you
basically already know everything you
need to know about the new generation of
iphones so now we have iphone 12 mini
and iphone 12 pro max
dropping at the same time opposite ends
of the spectrum so yes i am dropping two
videos at the same time this one is all
about the pro max and i'll link below
the video about the mini if you want to
check that out too so the pro max
is the everything phone it's the biggest
it's the most apple has to offer
fun fact even the sticker in the pro max
box is the biggest of any iphone box but
also now interestingly in the past
iphones have all just typically been the
same thing across the board but
different sizes maybe an extra camera in
the pro
this year there's an entirely new
different special camera system in just
the pro max that's not in any of the
other new iphones so naturally this was
the focus of my testing
that's a pun so i think all the other
benefits of a bigger iphone sort of
speak for themselves right the display
is a slightly higher resolution and it's
of course now a 6.7 inch screen instead
of the 6.5 inch from last year's max so
this is the biggest canvas of a screen
apple's ever put in a phone i would have
really really liked for them to make it
high refresh rate but again in the
reviews i talked about why it's not
there most likely battery but in every
other metric this is a top of the line
excellent smartphone display but also
speaking of battery the iphone 12 pro
max does have the biggest battery in any
of the new iphones and yes it does last
noticeably longer first of all it has an
incredible standby time and i've
typically ended days with it around 25
with six maybe seven hours of screen on
time sometimes so if you're looking for
the iphone with the best battery this is
definitely it it's comparable to the 11
pro max i would say maybe just a tiny
bit less then also the biggest iphone
does technically also get the biggest
speaker if you look at the bottom of all
these phones the 12 pro max has a bigger
grille than the others but honestly it's
not a noticeably louder speaker at all
really i just found it has slightly
bassier sound at the highest volumes
that's about it and the biggest iphone
also will of course have the biggest
viewing area and also because it's the
same size notch on a bigger screen the
notch kind of feels maybe a tiny bit
smaller even though it is still
comically big compared to other phones
but this is at least a no-brainer of a
choice of an iphone if people want to
watch videos do a lot of typing a lot of
texting a lot of photo editing big
screen stuff like that if you're not
used to the size of this bigger iphone
it's gonna feel huge like the toughest
thing is you'll notice right from the
start reachability is kind of tough you
can't reach all four corners of this
phone with one hand like you can with
the mini for example but other than that
i have no problems with it also side
note this is my first time using the
gold iphone
and sheesh this is a shiny gold outside
rail the back of the phone actually
isn't that gold it's more kind of like
an off-white sand color with the matte
finish and then the rings around the
camera and the stainless steel sides are
the really gold part
but they're still going to collect
fingerprints like crazy honestly it's
not the color i would pick but they
don't have like a matte black pro iphone
this year so i guess i could just pick
any color and then grab a dbrand skin
literally just for the side rails did
you know you could do that
yeah just matte black for the shiny
sides and all my complaints are solved
so i'll drop a link below if you want to
do the same thing shout out to dbrand
for being a channel sponsor but enough
of that what you're probably here for
is this camera right the question is is
this new camera system on the 12 pro max
worth like spending the extra money and
getting it over the 12 or the 12 pro if
you're a creator if you're a pro
no so first of all okay i just want to
point out it really is a physically
larger camera module like the rounded
circle that the cameras live on is
bigger and the camera rings and lenses
themselves are all also bigger
and that's to house the new hardware
inside namely the 47 larger main camera
sensor that now has sensor shift
stabilization instead of lens based
stabilization and there's also a new 2.5
x telephoto lens so that's huge
literally like a physically larger
sensor plus better stabilization
just screams like way better light
gathering abilities so i'd be looking
for improvements not just in regular
everyday photos in normal situations but
especially in lower light when you need
to maximize light gathering so ideally
you see better night mode performance
you see
maybe even not having to kick into night
mode as often because it's gathering so
much light and maybe even not having to
hold the phone still for as long when
you do have to kick into night mode
but i found none of these things to
actually be true now trust me i really
wanted to see a difference like this is
the one with the actually new camera
hardware this is the first big jump for
the iphone in a little while with the
cameras with the bigger sensor i was
hoping maybe to see some more natural
depth or some more of that bigger sensor
look that photographers know to look for
and i didn't see much of that to be
honest you could already get a solid
amount of natural bokeh without portrait
mode on plenty of smartphone cameras
including other iphones this one's no
different still takes great photos and
videos with smart hdr still does all the
typical iphone computational photography
all that's great
i'm just not seeing much of a difference
versus the other new iphone 12s so at
this point i'm like all right maybe to
see the difference i i just got to put
it side by side like most people won't
do that and that's actually a telltale
sign of a feature that probably regular
people won't notice is if you have to
put it side by side with something else
to even see it in the first place
but i want to see the difference i'm
testing them i'm testing the mini at the
same time so i'm going around with both
the 12 pro max and the 12 mini taking
photos side by side and when i tell you
i couldn't see much of a difference i
mean seriously you're seeing the results
here for yourself i did a back to back
photo testing in regular light and even
much more here in lower light where i
was expecting to see the bigger sensor
and better stabilization shine and show
me a difference and believe it or not i
just didn't so the only really
noticeable stuff i can point to between
the mini and the pro max seems to be
slightly better edge sharpness and some
of those wider landscape type shots
but in the dark i didn't see any
noticeably lower noise levels i didn't
see any shorter night mode stabilization
times i didn't see a much of the better
quality in low light shots i was hoping
to now again let's not forget it is
still really impressive photography in
this low light and in regular light it
really speaks to i guess how good the
computational photography and iphones
has gotten over the years more than
anything bad about the pro max phone
by the way it also doesn't fix any of
the haloing sort of glowing orbs you see
in nighttime videography they still show
up pretty much anytime there's a point
light in the scene in low light video
something i noticed when i first started
testing the 12s so all right the main
camera
i've tested it it's physically different
yes but the results are very difficult
to see any differences with i'm glad i
tested it but we can't forget there's
also a second uh telephoto lens there's
the 2.5 x instead of 2x so my
photographer friends out there that's
about a 65 millimeter equivalent instead
of 52 millimeters it's not a dramatic
difference as you may have guessed but
yeah it's right there now now there's a
2.5 x button in the camera now and the
final maximum allowed zoom in camera is
12x instead of the usual 5 or 10x yeah
it didn't make a massive difference for
me really what i actually noticed more
is getting locked into 2.5x or 1x for
portrait mode shots because regular
iphone 12 pro does portrait mode at 1x
and 2x so this one punching in a little
bit further starting to get a little bit
further away but i still stick with 1x
for portrait mode when i can so yeah i
guess the story
is apple
finally made a jump in hardware
and nothing really happened not much
happened i mean i was kind of hoping for
a bigger jump
in hardware to be honest
like if you just pay attention to
iphones you might think oh they finally
made a 50 bigger sensor that's a big
deal but if you look at the rest of the
world around the iphone there's a lot of
crazy hardware stuff going on there's 50
60 100 megapixel sensors there's 8k
video happening there's 3x 5x 10x
telephotos with periscope lenses inside
there's incredible computational
photography and
gimbal mode stabilization like there is
a lot going on with hardware advances
available for cameras but that's not the
apple way of course the apple way is
more sit back
take a take the landscape in see what
sticks around for a while and starts to
become an obvious benefit then grab that
make it a little better make it the
apple thing fit into the ecosystem
puzzle
unless it's usbc so yeah the camera in
the 12 pro max i'm just going to go
ahead and say is not the biggest reason
for you to upgrade to it
but this is definitely the phone you
should get if you want the biggest
iphone i mean it's clearly the biggest
and best battery it's the biggest and
best screen it's your biggest and best
viewfinder biggest and best keyboard
biggest and best iphone for sure that's
what i'd recommend for this
so i don't know maybe uh
maybe the 12 pro isn't such a bad move
after all or just stick with the 12. i
don't know all the reviews are out now
you can check it out let me know what
you think would you spend the 1100 bucks
on the 12 pro max
or would you settle for a different
iphone let me know in the comments let's
hang out there either way that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys soon
peace